this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house what's
happening you bad [__] it's
thursday the 28th of july
the joint is brought to you by blue chew
listen
confidence can take you far in life it
could also take you far in the bedroom
that's where blue chew comes in blue
chew is an online service that delivers
the same active ingredients as viagra
and cialis but in a chewable tablet at a
fraction of the cost you could take
these pills anytime anywhere
and be ready whenever the opportunity
arises let's pretend you're going to
wash laundry and you bump into a victim
and uh on the drive home you pop your
little pillow it's in your wallet it
comes in a little container personal
packages a pouch and that's it you're
ready to rock and i know you probably
don't have erectile dysfunction but you
always want to show up with a backup
right you're not going to show up to a
[__] wall with one gun you're going
to show up with three guns the same
thing it is with blue chew so do me a
favor the process is simple you sign up
at bluetooth.com consult one of the
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you'll receive
your prescription within days the best
part is it's all done online no doctor's
office no no brow beating no waiting in
line at the pharmacy bluetooth tablets
are made in the us of a jack
shipped in a discrete package your
mailman won't even know it so you could
benefit from the extra confidence when
it's time to sling dick
blue chew can help try blue chew for
free what did you say free [__] sucker
when using promo code joey j-o-e-y just
pay a fin
five dollars for shipping bluetooth
code joey for your first month free do
me a favor visit bluetooth.com
to get your free
little [__] blue nightmares
and for important safety information i
want to thank bluechu for sponsoring the
podcast the joint is also brought to you
by draftkings ufc 277 is on deck jack
and you draftking sportsbook is ready to
go they're the official sports betting
partner of the ufc now this saturday
juliana pena the rematch against amanda
nunes new customers you bet five dollars
on any fighter to win and i'm gonna get
you 100 free bets win or lose
want even more action here's where the
party starts you can also double your
winnings on the same game paul a combine
multiple bets like which fighter will
win and how long the fight will last
just place your bet place your little
[__] action with ufc
277 same game paulie if it's hits you
win double if you had the more legs you
had
the more money you win i'm excited
for [__] brian moreno i'm excited to
see the black beast
i'm very excited for juliana pena so if
i was you download the draftkings
sportsbook app now
use promo code joey better finn and any
ufc fighter to win and get a hundred and
free bets no matter what that's called
joey this saturday at draft king
sportsbook the official sports betting
partner remember draftkings is safe
secure and reliable withdraw your cash
whenever the hell you want you
understand me so do me a favor download
the draftking sportsbook app use promo
code joey and get ready to put 100 and
free bets in your pocket no matter what
the joint is also brought to you by
stamps.com
listen when you're running a small
business every second counts and every
dollar counts time is money chop chop
why go to the post office when you could
be using stamps.com make shipping and
mailing quick easy and cost effective
now
how easy is stamps.com jesus christ they
give you access to all post office and
ups shipping services save up to 30 off
on usps rates and over 86 on ups all you
need is a regular computer and a printer
print official postage for any letter
any package anywhere so do me a favor
stop wasting your time
we've been on stamps.com since 2009 my
wife loves it i love it you package it
you put it in the box the mailman picks
it up it's that easy stop saving time
and start saving money with stamps.com
no long term commitments or contract
just go to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the page and
then to code joey it's that simple
now with that let's get this party
started
it's thursday i got a lot to talk about
welcome to uncle joey's joint
[Music]
so
what's happening you bad [__]
it's thursday the 28th sorry about this
week we didn't put a podcast on on
monday and wednesday we switched it up
to tuesday and thursday because we were
busy it was a [__] weekend
we're out there doing things but anyway
it's a great [__] day to be
alive i don't know if you guys saw it
yesterday
i put the tickets up for sale my
residency in new york city at the sony
[__] theater
uh
the first one kicks open september 17th
i gotta be honest with you guys i'm a
little [__] excited when i saw the
post and that's not gonna be the real
poster but when i saw the poster it made
my [__] dick hard all right
i'm happy i could do comedy i have to
get on planes i don't have to deal with
20 000 people
or the [__] it's exactly what the
[__] i wanted
today we're going to talk a little bit
about planning
like when you have a career
like i had no [__] planning at all so
i did what i did
yes there was a plan
but i never put a time window on it the
reason why i want to talk to you about
this today is because
i was talking to our guest
who you'll see later on in the [__]
zoom
and we were talking about
uh the window
that is whatever you decide to go in i
recently found out not recently a couple
years ago that the nfl running back
the average uh career span is like three
or four years or something like that
they get hurt but then you see like
walter payton's and all that [__] and
people who've lasted
dozens of careers you know eight years
nine years 10 years anyway
and it's just so weird how
i wish i would have done things
differently as a comic even though
you know things happen the way they did
sometimes i'm like [__] i wish i would
have had
if i would have had an income coming in
the daytime i wouldn't have done
the desperate things i did at night i'm
gonna tell you one of the most desperate
things i [__] like there was one
christmas after the sopranos guys i
think it was uh
the christmas of 2007. i had just gotten
off a coke
and uh
that december you know it was like any
other december
my career only worked in september and
december december for me in the film
world
is uh
[__] tremendous you know what i would
do in [__] december in september
that was my month too so
what was i talking about i don't even
[__] know that vapor pain killed me
so this one december uh
you know
i
i always figured out a way to pay for
christmas you know like we all have
[__] christmas comes and we don't put
[__] away and we save uh christmas
shopping for the 23rd or the 24th that's
me you know that's how i
i didn't have money to [__] buy
november
or laying away [__] there was nothing
like that in my life you know layaway
so [__] uh
you know every year like one year i was
[__] broke in 2002
and i went to an audition and uh
i didn't get the part it was some stupid
thing but on the way out some guy came
up and said hey man i'm doing these
commercials and you're [__] perfect i
could cast you right now
the only problem is it's a non-union
commercial and
but you're gonna make three thousand
dollars for two days flat pay and i'm
like
you know because usually when you shoot
a commercial
they you shoot the commercial and then
they pay you to hold you
in the different markets
so you know exactly what's going on when
it's non-union they just give you a
one-time shot now maybe on that
commercial i could have made 50 000
who gave a [__] the the you know the
reason i did
all that these jobs was because i wasn't
putting money away i was too busy being
a [__] junkie now the holidays coming
i got no [__] money
so i had to work three days on a mars
bar commercial but this [__]
gave me three thousand dollars
in cash like in twenties
i hadn't seen three thousand dollars in
cash in twenty since i [__] sold coke
so i'm like yeah you know you gotta do
what you got to do but every [__]
december
i would always nail something there's
one year here's the year i quit coke
i'm thinking [__] life is great
fit soda [__] i'm thinking to
myself life is great
you know i'm clean
but my money was light for the holidays
and you know i i look at listen when
you're a comic whatever you do
you look at breakdowns breakdowns of
what jobs are coming up i look at uh
cass net i think at the time had little
jobs actors access
had jobs that's how i booked co-case i
booked a couple things off actors axis
where you submit yourself
i submitted myself for a soprano
christmas dinner
i've never told anybody this [__] so i'm
telling you today that's how broke i was
guys you know
hi
don't embarrass me more than when i'm
embarrassed mike
it's hard enough for me to get the
[__] words out you know
so i had to go to like [__] orange
county on a sunday night i had to be
there at six and there was a look-alike
paulie who didn't look like paulie it
was a lookalike tony who
uh in real life he was tony soprano's
double on the on the job he did a lot of
dublin for him
and then there was a chris maltesani who
was just an italian kid
and i was supposed to be [__]
they were gonna pay me 750
for the christmas party so what you had
to do is
is walk in they gave you a wardrobe
which i brought my own because they were
giving me gonna give me some low racket
bracket jacket
so i brought my own and i [__] uh you
have to walk in everybody claps
you know i'm feeling really [__]
creepy at this point
and i sit down and they start talking to
me and my [__] italian and [__] and i
got to make believe like i i'm oh yeah
i'm a big [__]
it was [__] embarrassing guys so
what you do is i think they showed an
episode
and then we ate some horrible ravioli
and [__]
and then we have to go mingle for two
hours with people
and guys that's why i don't go to comic
cons
like my brothers are you gonna go to
comic cons you'll make so much money
listen i don't want to talk to nobody
what are you going to talk about what
are you going to talk about when you get
the longest shot you want me to wear my
shirt and my helmet and live in that
[__] house i don't like none of that
[__] guys
there's this there's things that people
could do and they're still like i can't
do cameo i don't want to do cameo when i
do cameo it's [__] later you know i i
wanted i wanted to take that yeah i
wanted to take a break from [__]
videos because how many videos that we
got up with just smoking dope and
whatnot so anyway [__] uh
i had to talk to these people for two
hours
and i don't know who was worse the cast
that i had to sit with or them the
people were like [__]
asking me stupid questions and [__] and
then when i go find
refuge at the table
those guys were pounding me listen we
could do this everywhere we could do
this as a tour and i'm like
guys i don't want to do no tour i don't
even want to do this i'm just doing this
for the small 750 just so i could buy my
girlfriend's [__] something i'm not
doing this for a door dog it didn't stop
then like we should do a tour and the
guy that put it together he's like oh my
god we should do it [__] uh for
valentine's day and then for mother's
day and they want to do like a teen and
tony's wedding and i'm like oh god and
the whole time you know me i'm yes them
to death
you know the guys and the guy's like i'm
going to give you a bonus this is great
he gave me like a 50 bonus
but
those dudes
were so [__] like desperate like it
was like
you know when somebody comes up to you
and he says i'm tony soprano's body
double
you know i wouldn't tell nobody if i was
tony soprano's body double like uh
that's me getting shot that's me getting
thrown into rivers
that's me walking on [__]
i i i just can't you know i just can't
so i did that guys and i can't tell you
how embarrassed i was and for three
months after that that promoter
and each one of those characters called
my house or sent me emails
i only did once [__] you
once was enough
i went home and i'm like i gotta work a
little harder as a comic it's time to
it's time to write some [__] goodies
here make some joey karate videos
something that's when all that [__] came
up when you know you're just shooting
[__]
there's another thing i did one
christmas it's on [__] youtube
somebody sent it to me
i was it was like a week before [__]
christmas
and i got a call from a dear friend of
mine he's like hey joey we're in a spot
we hired a fat actor
and he didn't show up
you know and we need to do this scene
today
because it was the holidays like they
need to do the we're breaking on [__]
thursday it's tuesday we need this
[__] fat guy
listen don't take any insult to this but
would you do this
and i go what's your pay and they're
like 500 and i'm like
i was holding out he was a friend of
mine he goes hold on one second
he comes back on the phone he goes i get
you a thousand dollars like where is it
he goes downtown l.a
i went all the way down there i get that
guys and i'm they take me a guy come on
joey yeah he shakes my hand he walks me
into the back of these really creepy
looking women
they were all big and [__] they had blue
hair and stuff and they weren't very
nice they sat me down they go take off
your clothes and i'm like what
and they're like take off your car i'm
not taking off [__] they're like we
gotta uh
powder you
i go what and they're like yeah you
don't even know what the scene is you're
playing a cherub
with little underwears on and [__]
they're gonna put candies all over you
or something i don't [__] know and
they gotta rip them off i'm meanwhile
i'm 400 [__] pounds
and i'm sitting on this couch like this
like a cherub and i'm [__]
no and i'm naked all the way to the
[__] tongue and i'm sitting there
like this and i'm like and they're
putting stuff on me guys on the ride
home i think i cried
i [__] cried on the ride home i got
on i got into this
to do stand-up not to be a sopranos body
double not to be a [__] whatever so i
was like that's it i got to work harder
but these are the jobs that you do
to make ends meet
sometimes you got to do these jobs it's
like you mike has a band and they want
to play rock music they want to play
nirvana they want but one day they get a
call to do a wedding
and they got to switch it up
nobody wants to hear nevada the [__]
wedding they want to hear uh you know uh
i don't wanna dance whatever all those
creepy [__] songs at a wedding
now and forever all that [__] you know
you know [__] uh
[__] looks that kill is not gonna
work at somebody's [__] wedding
every time those guys do that they're
breaking away from who they are
and it's painful
even if they're getting 1500 from the
gig and they can split it three ways
it's painful because that's not what you
set out to do
and listen experience is experience okay
when you're a third year comic if
somebody says to you listen we want you
to [__] warm up at a strip club
you're gonna bomb every show
you've been bombing for years as an
opener and now you're gonna bomb for
sure you're gonna dread that [__] job
of going down to that strip club it
sounds luxurious you get a dinner you
get a [__] you get to see the
strippers then you get down and the
strippers are junkies the steak got
pubic hairs on them and the [__]
spell you know but this is what it is
i'd rather
do that
in a comedy club or less places dirty
then [__] have to do something that i
didn't want to [__] do and trust me
guys as a comic i did thousands of
things
that i look at now and i go what the
[__] was i thinking you know i didn't
suck a dick i didn't take it in the ass
but shooting me
naked with the thong on
picking cherries out of my [__] neck
and all that [__]
that's humiliating that is humiliating
yeah when you look at the check it makes
things better i remember i was watching
d.l hewley one night
and he came on he goes i know you
[__] watch soul plane
he goes how do you think i felt cash in
that check i had to wear a [__]
disguise to the bank
i [__] lost it because i know exactly
how he felt you know
you just do some creepy [__] things
well there was a one time when i was
doing a bunch of non-union [__] and i
would have to go there on thursday every
thursday at 7 00 am
they would pay me 500
to sweep
it was like an ad for a bus company or
something in europe
and i would be on marina del rey and it
would show the ocean and there'd be a
fence and all i have to do
is sweep just do this
like sweep and do a little dance
and then just stand there and put the
broom down and go
and then that's it i would do that every
[__] thursday for the small nickel i
have to get up at [__] 5 30.
yes what is it joey it was a commercial
for something in europe and here i am
dancing to some european music i don't
even know what it is i never seen the
final product
there's people in europe right now that
probably hate me i don't [__] know
but my point is guys
that it's always great to have
something that you make if i could do it
all over again i would have had a
security blanket something
something i would have had some type of
safety net 20 hours
30 hours that i could [__] collect
the pension and if the comedy looks like
it's starting to really [__] take off
dave chappelle's flying you around a
helicopter then i guess you [__] quit
you know what i'm saying
but uh
that that you know it's just so weird
like when you
think you want to be a musician or you
think you know it's like if you're an
artist and you want to draw art and also
somebody comes to you and says i want
you to paint an attic
you know you're like what the [__] well
a thousand dollars i could use the money
you'll paint the [__] addict and put
a [__] prince signature up there you
know that [__] thing the sign
whatever the [__] but
so plan it out guys i know it's cool not
to do comedy and to [__] have a day
job it's not cool it's not cool i mean
some of my best times was hanging out
with ralphie mae at his house and
writing jokes in the afternoon smoking
pots splitting the [__]
sandwich and and that's what it's about
to be a comic
but always have your bases covered
because you don't want to be like your
uncle joe you have to do things you
don't want to [__] do and then you
get there you're like what the [__]
if you ever see
like i did national lampoons
dirty show
in 1998 me rich
brian holtzman oh my god a bunch of us i
never
when you see that you're like holy [__]
that's really bad but they paid me a
thousand bucks you know i sold my
[__] soul you know what i'm saying
but
like i said before it's better than
getting a massage from harvey weinstein
you know what i'm talking about i'd
rather [__] do a job that i don't
want to do
then get a job from uh harvey weinstein
anyway
i got a [__] guess today how's that
for you [__] i've been talking
your ears off giving your goddamn ear
beatings and [__] it's over i had to get
a guest in here you can't put all the
weight on me in the next couple of weeks
we're gonna have some more interesting
guests tj
english is coming in to below his book i
got [__] some surprise guests we're
gonna try at least what i'm saying but
today
we got chris camozzi and uh we're
talking about
fitzsota the company he works for and
we're always talking about uh just fight
careers in ufc we forgot to talk about
ufc
277 and have some picks but i did uh
mma junkie this morning and uh
we made some picks on there i don't know
if i'll bet those [__] but
anyway
i love you [__] i won't see you
afterward we're gonna go write the
[__] ads
i'll see you monday tip top magoo
ready to [__] go i love you at all my
heart don't forget ufc this week stay
out and don't forget
sony peter the tickets are up the rest
is up to you if you haven't been to new
york lately fly in take your wife to
dinner i don't know bring mom come visit
your [__] grandchildren whatever i'm
not coming to you this year you're
coming to me until february so
sony hall.com for tickets 40 tickets 10
service fee i tried to keep them low for
you [__] i love you enjoy chris
[Music]
joey's camozzi
what's happening
you handsome w
how are you doing i figured it out
finally i use my phone i know you would
you're a [__] smart guy it's funny i
told the i was mma junkie wanted me to
call in today
and i go the time they gave me i go now
i gotta call in to chris camozzi and he
goes send chris my love and tell him his
girlfriend is beautiful i go you [__]
tell him
she is a [__] knockout i know both of
them are [__] beautiful you don't
know who you want to swap spit with
i appreciate it she was out here helping
me try to figure out the computer and
then i was like i'm just gonna use the
phone i don't know [__] it you look
great how's denver
it's good man it's been hot you're out
there
man i've been in denver since like 97.
holy [__]
yeah haven't left
that's a long time
yeah i mean i like this city one of
these days i should probably move out
and branch out a little bit but it's a
fun city no you're young that's a great
place to be man
yeah and you uh you used to come out
here you used to live out here a long
time ago right i [__]
you came out from long island right
no i i uh moved here with my family from
the bay area in california
oh i did you're a long island boy for
some reason
no i just go out there a lot train with
those guys okay that's what it is no i
went out there
a friend of mine was big out there like
he had settled out there after college
and he invited me out and i thought it
was great but we lived in
basalt colorado then which is next to
aspen
yeah i moved to snowmass village
and then
i wasn't a big boulder dude there was
too many [__] hippies walking around
at that time a lot of stinky people
the first time i went to boulder i'm
like i'll never come back here that's
how strong i was against boulder i'm
like i'll never come back here
and then in 85 i went back i left denver
about a year
and i was headed to colorado springs and
on the plane
some black dude was like nah man you
ain't gonna go down there and hang out
with [__] the army you need to be in
boulder where the [__] at and i'm
like what are you talking i was 21 he
goes you're a young guy go to boulder
and i fell in love with it that time and
i stayed from uh 95 to i was a colorado
person from 83
to 95.
oh no [__] i know you're out here that
long and i started denver i started
comedy in denver and i got locked up in
colorado
i'm telling you
yeah so colorado and me have a great
[__] relationship i love it there
i won't go back to boulder because i'm
embarrassed
you know what i mean like seriously i
won't go back to bold because after i
left that i realized how much havoc i
caused in a beautiful community
oh i mean they caused their own havoc
now he was one of the party schools out
there
but it was [__] nuts in boulder now
it's a little bit more calm i guess i
haven't been there in 20 years
man i don't know if you'd like it now
it's uh it's beautiful right but there's
still the hippies there but they're all
hippies with money so they're very like
snobby snowy i'll probably get some
flack for that since i live right here
but no you won't they know it they know
they call boulder the people's republic
of boulder anyway
it's its own [__] country in there
like that's why when the shooting
happened last year i was in shock for
like a week
yeah is that supposed to happen in
boulder
no i mean they're they're about as
liberal as it gets and it's very like
peace and love hippie out there um yeah
i was surprised too when that whole
thing went down i was like boulder what
i was in shock
it kind of bothered me a little bit i
used to shop at that king supers that
was i used to shoplift at that king soup
because that was my
favorite the seafood department the guy
would just give us food he'd go just
walk out with it don't put it on me
because you know they tried you with
seafood
he wouldn't charge us he'd go i know you
guys are shoplifting
so that's a good dude right there good
[__] dude from louisiana i never
forgot him you still fighting
yeah man so i haven't like officially
retired or anything i've just been on a
delay on my free agent right now
i left the pfl last year i went through
their season um did real well
and now just kind of like sorting out
some options you know i'm i'll do it a
few more years probably if it's
available but man the money's got to be
right you know i love doing it
fighting's my favorite thing to do um i
still train every day but
out the days of like going in there and
sacrificing myself for these promoters
to make all the money is kind of over
it's a [__] nightmare ain't it man
the business side of it all you want to
do is fight all i want to do is crack
stupid [__] jokes
yeah then you look at the contracts and
you're like what the [__] happened to
the jokes
they're sucking me dry here
you know they give you money but then
they're like oh you got to pay for this
you got to pay for that you got to pay
for and people have no idea how many
expenses you get
when you work theaters and [__] like
that and then they contact you for money
for promotion and you're like what are
you talking about
you're not even
buying ads or anything
you're [__] putting a little flyer on
your table
yeah
i guess it's got to be the same
with the ufc uh a buddy of mine called
me then he wants me to read his book
and he won it's it's an ex it's uh
something he called an expose on the nfl
you know like oh wow you grow up all
your life wanted to play football and
then you get to the nfl and they break
your balls from a to z
you know like if the nfl likes you they
work with you
if not i did the longest shot with brian
bosworth and he told me they used to
find him
his game salary for wearing his shirt
outside his pants
yeah they have a ton of fines i think
even if like the they wear the eye paint
you know if that runs down and it's not
clean i a few of my buddies in the nfl
were telling me like the list of fines
that those guys can get each game
it's insane it's [__] insane
yeah
but yeah it's um no i'll probably fight
a couple more times we'll see like i
said the money's got to make sense it's
a weird game now like like you were just
saying it uh
now they're they're like how many
followers do you have these promoters
you know how many tickets do you sell
all of this i just had this conversation
with a promoter recently where he's like
well how many tickets are you gonna sell
and i said well at some point it's your
job to be the promoter and promote the
fight i show up and fight if you want me
to do both and pay me for both jobs
that didn't go over that well
no it doesn't it never does they don't
like that
they want people who just say yes and
play that [__] song but then you read
through it and you start going
i work so hard i work seven days a week
on this
and i'm giving away this [__] money
to these people who are just basically
pimps
yeah i mean that's one thing
i'll say
i'll say the best thing about the ufc is
they never mention ticket sales to you
they don't ask you to sell a thing they
just ask you to show up do your job they
take care of it they're like a marketing
machine you know so they they deserve a
ton of credit in that way because i know
even like promotions like bellator and
stuff has some of those fighters to be
slanging tickets you know and you're
trying to focus on training and working
and working out and not getting your
head taken off
so
that's just an extra step that most of
these promotions are throwing in there
on you now what the what do they want
you to do go to a [__] mall
and give away tickets in the mall try to
convince people to buy tickets at the
mall like
it's
people either want to go or they don't
want to go chris
yeah you know i agree it's always uh you
get
in my world it was always
up front
and then two days before the show you
sell all these tickets
because people have to make up their
minds what the [__] they're doing i know
if you call me and well
i'm playing uh on november 11th
i'm not going to buy those tickets to
like october mid-october unless you call
me and go they're selling out really
quick
because i don't know what the [__] i'm
doing november 11th or whatever the [__]
it is so
yeah i'm the same way i don't even know
what i'm doing tomorrow you know i don't
even know if i'm going to be alive then
so lately
i [__] hate making plans sometimes
then they call you back well if we don't
meet on this okay you're like wow
let's just me let's just get to the
[__] meat
and then we'll worry about the variables
and stuff like that so you contacted me
you always you're always a good [__]
dude you always talk to me and [__] but
you sent me some fit soda
and it blew my [__] mind
the lemon lime and the originals you
sent me were lemon lime and
[__] uh the orange
vanilla blend i forget what they call
that [__] the dreamsicle
yeah the orange cream oh my god oh my
[__] god that orange cream is
tremendous
i just uh
i just had some more sent out to you the
other day so you should be getting it
thank you and then you sent me the the
cherry
yeah there's cherry coke like a cherry
coke some type of thing
yeah black cherry cola and then root
beer vanilla float let me tell you
something the root beer vanilla float i
drank that [__] after i smoked three
[__] joints you understand that [__]
takes it to the next level
that's my favorite i tell you what i
think my favorites are
[__] creamsicle
by
them and the
root beer float is
tied
i mean they're [__] delicious and
[__] and i like the lemon lime is up
there too i think black cherry is the
only one i'm kind of weird with i
finished them already don't get me wrong
i drink them you know i love that [__]
after you work out
but what are they for are they after
workout pre-workout
so it's all the above right it's a
hydration drink it's a it's a healthier
option to soda so
essentially you know
most of us as kids drink soda and
everything is full of sugar it's full of
all that crap i mean coca-cola we use it
to take acid off the car battery you
know imagine what that does to your
stomach
so
fit soda came in their their original
product was coyos which is a nootropic
drink
good for your brains got a ton of
vitamins and stuff in it and then fit
soda now is the the newer product what
that is is it's hydrating but it tastes
like soda it's got electrolytes in it
it's got bcaas in it
no calories no sugar
so it's a healthier option for you like
kids can drink it there's no caffeine in
it we're making an energy drink form
most likely and we've got a few other
ideas some new flavors coming out but
you can drink them all day long you know
you don't need a reason to drink it
not the other one there
right here you bad [__]
goddamn delicious [__]
that's my favorite one
this is superb
yeah yeah and so like with me working
for them now you know i'm the brand
manager um that's kind of what put me in
this position with uh the fight
promotions that's why i've been out so
long is i don't need it like i don't
need to fight i want to fight so i'm
just looking for the right deal that
works for me that that's worth the time
and you know sacrificing my body like i
said so it's a good option to have
because a lot of fighters in the
beginning
that's all they do you know and so
there's guys i know that take fights
just because they need the money it's
not even a good match-up for them it's
not a good show
stuff like that you know i see it in the
gym all the time guys are like well i
gotta do it even if even if they're hurt
or whatever so now i put myself in a
position to
actually be able to choose i can sit
back and uh decide when i want to fight
where i want to fight and if it makes
sense so
it's been a great thing because they
started out as one of my sponsors i was
the first athlete they ever had
and then just building that relationship
over time turned into a job
it's [__] the way it happens brother
but you know you brought up a great
point
chris when i got into comedy
if you had a day job you were a [__]
momo
yeah
and your job was to get good at comedy
so you didn't have to have a day job
anymore and then you get to the point
where you're like all right i'm ready to
cross over
and then you
give up your job you tell your boss to
suck your dick
and you go on your journey as a comic
and that's all great and dandy but now
looking at lives and how times have
changed
for me right now i wish i wouldn't had
the felonies
because i would have got a day job
i would have got a great day job
and i would have became a weekend comic
that just goes out friday the job would
understand
listen i leave friday mornings i'm here
all week with you i'll sell everything
you want me to sell but friday
i go to nebraska you know you don't have
to be at a punch line to be a great
comic
yeah you don't have to be a great
theater to be a great comic there's a
thousand comics that make a living on
their terms they never wanted to push
the boundaries beyond that and i
appreciate it you know
now at 59 i'm
i love doing comedy and [__] but at the
same time i wish i would have had
something to retire from
yeah i didn't think that way when i
started and i didn't think that way
while i was doing it
but i think it would have gave me a i
would have been more relaxed i didn't
have to do
the things i didn't want to do those
stupid [__] gigs
you know so it's the same thing listen
fighting and comedy is an art
it's an art you know how i know because
i can learn
the same arm bar from closed guard
and learn it three different ways
you know like it's an art it's a it's a
breathing art so i underst i understood
fighting more
after i joined jiu jitsu and then i
mixed it all up together with comedy and
i see the comparisons with jiu jitsu and
comedy
after i get you laughing i gotta go to
my safe place that's my closed guard
yeah you know i see it that's why i
breathe that's why i get my thing and
then you it's the same thing breathing
so it's so weird with
i don't even know what i was going to
say i i shouldn't have smoked that pot
this morning but
no i shouldn't hit that vapor pen but
it's so weird how i learned you learn
from all three and i see fighters today
that you know how they're going to end
up
doesn't take a [__] you know we grew
up on boxing you look at how some of
these boxes end up you read a story 10
years from now they're broke they're in
a basement they did a crime they're in
prison
i think you're intelligent enough to
know that you wanted that security
and there's nothing wrong with that
and then overlapping them you know use
one for the other because now i've got
all these contacts from all over the
world um
and helping to build the brand of what
i'm doing
by using like friends and stuff not
using them but
uh now i work with the budget and
everything so i can turn around and pay
friends and be their sponsor
um you know people that make sense and
everything i still have to be smart with
the job but
i can use my fighting career to also
propel this career which was always my
plan and i wanted him to overlap i
didn't want to hit the end and then be
like now what the [__] am i gonna do you
know
right now i i have a nice calm life i'm
in jersey it's a little common in l.a a
lot calmer
but i wish i had somewhere to go every
day even if it was for six hours four
hours you know i'm like well how are you
gonna train in the daytime because i
hate going to the gym at night i could
lift weights at night but jiu jitsu by
the time i get there at six i already
ate a sandwich
now you gotta [__] roll you you know
it just sucks so
but i would have done it i i wish i
would have done like my friend sam
tripley now he's a comic but he also
runs like a similar youtube type
uh page you know and he gets a little
money from that
all that [__] helps and it's great to
still stay in
in the real world from time to time so
i get where you're coming from you're a
[__] smart dude man
trying to be not always but you know
sometimes when you're going to college
yet
i didn't so i went i actually went for
one semester um in durango colorado have
you ever been there
oh yeah it wasn't for me so uh i came
back
and then i just started working you know
i started working in clubs and stuff and
um from there i got into to training and
everything and then the first day i went
into an mma gym i was hooked
the first time you got punched in the
head you were ready to rock
oh yeah i mean i was getting fights all
over the place back then anyway and then
didn't know what i was doing but it
seemed to be working out for me and then
when i started actually learning
and you know doing muay thai doing
jiu-jitsu and stuff i actually stopped
getting in fights outside of the gym
because when you're in the gym you're
getting your ass kicked and you're
fighting people all the time the last
thing you want to do is do that when
you're having fun
and then it just kind of propelled you
know i started working night jobs so
that i could train all day
and then uh up until the ufc is when i
quit the clubs and then just went full
in on training
you missed the ufc
yeah yeah i mean i had a good time you
know i always had a good relationship
with them they were always um
they always treated me real well i would
still say it's the best run organization
in the world um they take care of
everything i know there's there's a lot
of people that complain about the
fighter pay and all of that like
everybody always wants to make more
money right like you want to make more
money i want to make more money i think
there'll always be that argument but one
thing i would say is that like
their health system as far as like
taking care of the fighters if you get
injured
is amazing their staff is amazing
anything you need
anything you want like fight week
they'll get it for you in and out of
camp like they have such a big
production
that they have somebody to contact you
for anything you need so it was actually
um
it was great to fight for them and like
see how professional it could be
one thing about the ufc and i you know i
read a lot about the fighter pay and
jake paul's beating people up and
you know he wants to beat up dana white
and [__] you know the whole thing but
you answered
my doubts when you said something
earlier
you said that when you fight for the ufc
you don't worry about selling tickets
somebody takes care of that for you
and that marketing machine behind ufc
is what you know i mean i look at some
of the fighter pay
and i know that they show comparison
sometimes like somebody said uh i don't
know somebody fought in bellator and the
guy made
a half a million more dollars than him
it's absurd
but yeah health care system
is big
if i get hurt i know i could do that you
could also train at that ufc [__]
duplex yeah in vegas which i heard his
state of the [__] art
oh it's amazing like i heard it's just
state of the art so
so a lot of people don't see that
yeah
i do think like the fighters do deserve
more money of course you know but um
you know i don't think a union would be
a bad idea um there's a lot of things
that could change but
as far as like fighting goes they're
still doing the best they're still on
top they're still taking care of
everybody um
at least better than every other
promotion right now so
i mean there's always going to be
improvements that could be made and you
know maybe in our lifetime we'll see
guys making the hundreds of millions of
dollars i honestly don't know where
boxing gets all the money we talk about
it all the time
the ticket prices
and the pay-per-view
they've been dominant they invented that
[__] system and the thievery and the
whole you know
mike tyson talks about it but
the ufc i mean listen
everybody's getting rich over there
don't think dana's doing this out of the
courtesy of his heart you know the
people
they're getting rich and uh
they have a big nut that's what a lot of
people understand also
they got a big [__] nut that's a big
nut that you don't see we don't see
everything i can't imagine what their
insurance bill is
oh i don't know i can't imagine so
before i complain and talk about
something i don't know
i did was a little disappointed about
the union not coming together because i
heard about this union
starting about three years ago and i
think the fighters really do need
but the problem with fighting
and the problem with stand-up comedy
is that while we're building our union
there's always one [__]
that goes around this and that'll work
for that pay or even less
exactly there's some schmuck that's
gonna be like i'll do it and then they
ruin it um
yeah i don't know i mean unions are
giving take two there's plenty of bad
things that come with the union so i
think it'll get dialed in but right now
like they're doing well those guys are
doing well the having the ufc during the
pandemic was the best there were no
other sports on i love what dana does
man like he he's definitely got balls
and he'll be the forefront he's the one
that built that company it is what it is
because of him
and uh and this isn't kissing ass it's
just that's good business hey listen i
got i love dana there's days i wake up
and i love dana and these days i wake up
and i go [__] dana what the [__] you
know
but at the end of the day he does a
great job
listen yeah it's here's the other
problem too chris which you
saw
you know
the nfl the longevity of a running back
is three years
when i heard that i almost died
because you play football all your life
you get to the pros you you run over
people in college and your longevity is
three years but not really then we have
barry sanders and we got the guy from
chicago you got all these greats that
played ten years whatever
the same with the ufc
it's a [__] coin toss like when i
first went to la i gave myself a year
if nothing happens in the year i'm going
to stop in colorado stab my ex-wife
and then go to jersey and nobody'll
[__] find me in jersey that was my
plan
but every time i shut that deadline down
i did something good
yeah i get a movie or a commercial or
somebody would tell you you're funny you
know so
with the ufc now when you go into it you
got to go into it with a plan
yeah i mean i would like to see those
guys have pensions and stuff like the
nfl guys i think it's five years in they
get you know pension for life and they
get health care for life um
that would be amazing for
mma you know because the guys come out
banged up i've got friends that are
retired that they're not the same
anymore oh
no
it's a toll
you know i was watching uh
barbarina against
the dude he's 40 years old tremendous
they just fought about two weeks ago
oh robbie lawler robbie lawler what a
great [__] fight the boxing robbie
lawler was great shots to the head then
barbarina came back and knocked bobby
out it was a great fight but it's brain
damage
man yeah one of those two
brain damage
i mean both of them prior waller's one
of my favorite fighters
you go back look at some of the battles
that guy's been in man it's
he's a savage
you know that's why i love like there's
a couple fight lists and fighting is
hard you've seen these uh
these legend jiu jitsu teachers
yeah they're legends they're great but
if you look at them now
watch when they walk in they don't walk
that good look at their hand grips
they're not that good you know that's
why i like alberto crane's tactical
fitness
i do this
oh my god he's got an app now
and uh you know i did jiu jitsu with
alberto i know alberto since i shot the
longest yard in new mexico before he
even dreamed
when he just had a little school and we
used to all go in
and break his balls but alberto has a
jiu jitsu school he's got a muay thai
class there
but the most the class that's growing
the most is a class he's got that's
called technical
technical whatever tac fit tactical
fitness
and it's basically active recovery it's
a five-day program
and you run it you can check that out
yeah you run it at the same time with
jiu-jitsu
or muay thai and it just takes care of
your shoulders your joints
it's really [__] dynamite it's a lot
of movement they don't have it here but
once they do start a school i mean he
sends me tapes from time to time
it's a yoga mix it's yoga with
kettlebells and club bats and
pull-ups and weird push-ups and [__] but
it's an active recovery and it's pretty
good for you
but that would be the plan to go into
the ufc with goals
fight every 120 days
just be a [__] savage for three years
yeah that's what i tried to do after
every fight i was like how soon can i
fight again you know you can only get so
long so i was lucky enough to be with
them for i think it was about eight
years i did 20 fights and then uh
yeah so i was just trying to stack them
up i was thinking the same thing i like
the paychecks
so i was like let me fight five six
times a year and just keep racking up
money
you know i know the tickets are
expensive for the ufc but i tell this to
everybody
i've been to boxing matches as a kid you
know at the gardens like the golden
globes and then
you know i've been to live football
games like basketball games they're all
great the the live experience is great
the ufc live experience
is also really great
oh yeah the whole [__] thing from the
prelims up to the main card with
with bruce buffer and you see all the
fighters coming in and you know
it's great i don't know if anybody has
done it i know it's expensive you know i
know that
some of the tickets are [__] high-end
but
just get yourself a cheap seat and go to
an event
and it's [__] life-changing guys it
really is you know i went to like thank
god i was friends with joe all those
years he brought me to like 30 events
i would have a blast at those things i'd
take edibles
i'd be gambling in the hallways with
people like we'd bring a bunch of
singles you know and five dollar bills
nothing none not hundreds and nothing
just people in the row
just people that are sitting around you
we get [__] around you know we got
alex jones high one time
we got him [__] baked on edibles and
he kept saying edibles don't do nothing
to me edibles don't do nothing to me and
finally he sat behind me i couldn't
figure out why
when the chick came by she's like hi
what are you what can i get you and he's
like what do you got
and she's like oh we have pretzels
peanuts hot dogs and something else and
he goes give me one of each
because they were [__] for free but i
looked at him i go i thought you weren't
i thought these things didn't get you
high [__] suckies over there eating
pretzels and [__] great times so if you
could catch a ufc fight
catch one
yeah i mean i haven't been to one in a
minute but even that uh you remember the
intro music i don't know if they still
do like the piano or whatever and then
it speeds up and it speeds up and stuff
no no it's a it's a
man
where can people buy this soda and read
more about it
because i think once people start
reading about this and they taste it
they're going to lose their [__]
minds like i did
yeah i mean check out fitsodas.com it's
the easiest we're on amazon we're in a
ton of major retailers on our website we
have a store locator we're in sprouts
nationwide
and a ton of other big stores but it
depends on the state you're in you know
you can get it on amazon i tell a lot of
people that's the best if you got prime
they'll ship it for free because you
know sodas are heavy but
yeah fitsodas.com
you can check out everything on there
the story all of that we're even
revamping the website and we have a lot
of big things coming we just haven't
announced it yet
where are you training these days
i trained at a genesis training academy
here in uh denver it's in arvada
actually
for mma that's where i do striking with
uh my coach named jake ramos
and then i do jiu jitsu at katharo
training center in littleton colorado
and i also coach over there too you're a
bad [__] dog
i bounced the city all day
well listen when i come out i'm gonna
come visit you [__] around with you
talk to my wife about she asked me what
do you want for your 60th birthday
she goes we got to start planning and i
don't want no [__] party
[__]
so i go i'll tell you what i would like
i would like to go to colorado and show
my daughter boulder
snowmass and go up to aspen that's the
week of bikini skiing
there you go skiing their bikinis and
[__] and they fall on the tip pops out
there no but i used to go there 20 years
ago i can't imagine now with all the
fake tits that come up from dallas
they [__] fly through the air one of
those tits blows up and you sail away
into [__] snow mess
chris i love you man
i'm happy you took the time today man
you're a good guy and i'm sorry we've
been playing phone tag it's just been
[__] crazy lately oh no no problem i
know you've been busy um i appreciate
you having me on
i always listen to your show i [__]
love you you know that
forever so keep me posted
you need something let me know and thank
you for the soda and we'll talk we'll
talk this weekend
yeah definitely come out to denver i'll
take you on a tour of livewell too
massive dispensary out here they're grow
houses some you've never seen before
really
yeah
live well it's like yeah livewell is the
biggest one around here they've been a
sponsor mine for a long time but their
grow house the one they have here in
denver is
200 000 square feet it's massive you'll
blow you it'll blow your mind i just
want to lay in the middle of it take a
nap
and see what happens with all that
[__] air and all those chemicals i
love you buddy
thank you for taking the time today and
i'll be in touch all right man
all right sounds good
beautiful tarzan you got it
all right you bad [__] the
joint is brought to you by
stamps.com listen when you're running a
small business
every second counts i'm going to make
your life a lot easier shipping mailing
quick easy and cost effective with
stamps.com stamps.com is going to give
you access to ups shipping services and
all post office services you're going to
save 30 on usps rates and you're going
to save 86 off ups listen i don't care
how small a business
your i don't care how small or bigger
your business is
if you're sending t-shirts in the mail
and if you're not working with
stamps.com just i don't know what to
tell you stop wasting time and start
saving money when you use stamps.com to
mail and ship sign up with promo code
joey and i'm going to give you a four
week trial plus free postage and a
digital scale no long term commitments
or contracts go to stamps.com click on
the microphone at the top of the page
and enter code joey it's that simple
listen this weekend i got some huge
fights i got a great card it's ufc 277
and then i'm wasting time all right
draftking sportsbook the official sports
betting partner the ufc has got a
tremendous offer for you this saturday
amanda nunes julian anna pena is the
rematch they're going to be throwing
[__] haymakers at each other you're
going to bet five hours on any fighter
to win and get 103 bets win or lose now
if you want more action
that's where draftking comes in with the
same game paulet combine multiple bets
like which fighter will win how long the
fight will last over two and a half
rounds under four whatever just place
your ufc 270 same same game paulie and
if this hits you hit double number two
you ready for this one the more legs you
add the more money you win you can pick
up submission there's a thousand things
i'm excited about ufc 277 because it's
the black beast it's brian moreno i mean
it's a tremendous card now draftkings is
safe secure and reliable you can
withdraw your cash whenever the hell you
want no questions asked download the
draftking sportsbook app now use promo
code joey j o e y
bet 5 on any ufc 277 fighter to win
and get 103 bets no matter what that's
code joey this saturday at draftkings
sportsbook the official sports betting
partner of the ufc the joint is also
brought to you by
blue chew listen we all need a hard dick
confidence can take you far in life
but guess what it can also help you in
the bedroom that's where blue chew comes
in blue chew is an online service that
delivers the same active ingredients as
viagra and cialis but the chewable
tablets at a fraction of the cost the
process is simple you sign up at
bluechew.com consult one of the licensed
medical providers and once you're
approved you receive the prescription
within days it's that [__] easy and
the best part it comes to your house no
doctors visits no pharmacy you don't
have to make eye contact bluetooth
tablets are made in the u.s of a and
shipped in a discrete package your
[__] mailman won't even know what's
in there if you could benefit from extra
confidence and trust me we all can
blue chew can help try blue shoe for
free when using promo code joey just pay
five dollars for shipping and you'll be
slinging dick like [__] will
chamberlain
i want to thank chris camozzi
i want to thank you guys for having my
[__] back too thick and thin stay
black
have a great weekend and i'll see you
[__] monday morning
tip top magoo
[Music]
you